The Oscars really want us.
I'm trying to keep it together.
I'm like, you gotta,
you,
huh?
(soft piano music)
- I was driving in rush
hour traffic on the 101,
and I got a call.
- Well, Packer actually
called us and said,
"Hey, like you're about to
actually present trophies
"at The Academy."
And I was like, oh, snap.
- And basically they're
looking into you and Josh
to be presenters at the Oscars.
I was like,
(woman laughing)
I was like, "Stop lying,
I have to finish packing."
Like, "What are you talking about?"
- I'm like, "Oh, she's serious."
Like, so the Oscars really want us.
I'm trying to keep it together.
I'm like, you gotta,
you,
huh?
- And I finally got off on
an exit and I pulled over
and, again, I tried to play it cool.
I was like, "Yeah, no, it's totally fine."
But I was like, "What
the hell's happening?"
And people like driving by
me and going around me and.
- It feels like it's a dream.
It feels like it's not actually real
or that I'm gonna wake up at some point.
- You know, once you guys
actually explained, you know,
what a trophy presenter
was, then I was like, oh,
so like you get to go on
stage and actually, you know,
give the trophies to the people.
- I've been to many an award ceremony,
but this is the mother
of all award ceremonies.
So I'm excited to just be present
and just sort of like take it all in.
- To have the opportunity to
just be in the same presence
of the people I look up
to, like role models,
being able to just see them.
- On the professor side, it's very cool,
'cause I get to watch how
things are put together.
It's information I can
share with my students.
It has an upside on that,
'cause at the end of the day,
the only reason I'll
mention this to students
is to help them make something, I think.
- I think that it's gonna
be exciting for my students
to just, at the very least,
and especially, you know,
my marginalized students,
to see somebody up there
and have a direct connection
to something that's felt so mystical
and so far out of reach.
- I watched the Oscars growing up.
In the past couple of years,
a lot of Mexican directors
have been nominated
and awarded in the Oscars,
and it's really such an honor
watching them be on stage.
And just seeing myself
with that possibility
of being on that stage, as well.
- I think now more than ever,
this is the most inclusion
that I've seen at the Oscars,
and I'm loving it.
- This was just a blessing to
be able to go to the Oscars,
but let alone go Oscars
by actually presenting
awards, present trophies
to people that are in
the movies that I watch
and for the people I look up to.